all right our last segment at for
today's Paris games week Sony and wrap
up is all about not what they showed but
what they didn't show just a notable
omission for you the eye there are so
many things you wanted to I wanted to
seen some things you know we're not
going to be there Michael and sell comes
out you're like I I know he's gonna talk
about the game is really about you're
gonna say guillermo del toro stands out
an alarum row b of the young good and
evil to never i know it's never gonna
happen i know that every time every time
he comes out on stage i just i want it
yeah and he probably wants to talk about
it as well oh you want to talk about
like oh yeah this is been cancelled this
isn't gonna happen haha what about games
we thought were counselled on how not
cancelled anymore Last Guardian no sign
of us in person yeah yeah and TGS there
was there was nothing new they had the
big they had that big screen that had
the Treecko monster come down but there
was no actual new gameplay that was the
exact same demo that we saw from e3 not
here at paris at all like I bet they're
showing the same demo on the TV screen
yeah the last you not to film it because
they've already shipped it and one thing
that didn't show at the conference that
I saw previously tweeted was heavy rain
coming to PlayStation 4 I saw Quantic
Dream tweeting that in the morning no
another thing news to me no really all
right let's check my Twitter again make
sure not stop there's a really great
YouTube video that if you guys have
after you're done watching this you
should check out a YouTube video of
heavy rain a blooper where all this guy
does this fail as he's chasing a guy
through a supermarket it's the funniest
thing it is heavy rain in a nutshell
yeah have your and ps4 shown at paris
games week apparently exactly is that a
real account is that a real account who
knows you can go find out yourself most
of the games price is following it so i
hope so I'm another game that was a lots
of song and dance about it at e3 and
then nothing's shown here at Shenmue 3
there's not surprised there's nothing to
show for that game but there's like hey
look it's got funded whoo they could
least it i could do though but think of
all the weird press they've been getting
like after that whole funding round they
don't know they're coming back and
saying we needed more money right like
that i think they're trying to avoid
that until they actually have some like
really interesting gameplay to show off
we're gonna talking about for like
immediately after three got funded
they're like yeah we're also planning at
some point doing for
chill out do this year Zuki let's take
this one step at a time you bastard
guess what now huh he's a lot of
enthusiasm I love the enthusiasm mmm Oh
Peter Molyneux you had that as well yeah
and everyone loves his enthusiasm and
nothing from Santa Monica I'm God of War
you're confused about that well I
wouldn't say confused i was expecting
some more god of war because we got the
god of war collection Jesus God avoids
it's about time for a new God we're sure
this isn't tired we're gonna get this
PlayStation experience I'm i'm betting
PlayStation experience new god of war
kratos better look different and be a
different I mean I'd a shirt alright oh
so old and tired at this point like
we've just he's done so much well
there's no one left the murder yes the
Pentagon has been emptied the Norris he
could go some Norse we're gonna go for
like judeo-christian God's next I'm just
applying for kid would say uncharted
cross gotta for yeah yeah I can mesh
those two I don't do Church I wish
they'd show more blood-borne maybe she
have literally this close to the
expansions release I wish they showed
they didn't show anything news more they
shone like the saw blade attacks and
everything which is gonna be awesome
when you actually get to play it but
short trailer it seem like most about it
already and shown though right yeah it's
more of ya tgs stuff yeah I just I I
can't wait for this this I'm looking
forward to this just as much as some
games coming out this fall and lash and
I think I was really hoping for
something more just because it's what
November 24th I think mmm it's you know
impending how're ya they would have done
some sort of ISA magician you don't know
spoil it too much maybe yeah I guess so
i can respect that but I'm sure
penetrator don't know me show me more
than this eyeball throat justin ryan you
were talking about so rhyme is a game
that looks absolutely beautiful and we
didn't see it at e3 this year either and
it's kind of like a zelda type adventure
and it was I think a playstation 4 expel
exclusive and has just been missing for
them over a year now they showed it at
Gamescom like two years ago yeah and
that was the only time we've we've seen
anything from it looks wonderful like oh
I was really looking forward to this
game it's like the wind waker but not a
place to like updated like oh this is
gonna be great and it's still gone any
idea where that was being developed was
it a European game perhaps they might
keep her for PlayStation experience then
yeah maybe I guess just if it was shown
at Gamescom you
thought then maybe it was the Europeans
to do yeah the like Paris would have
been the great time to bring this back I
think people like myself remember it and
they want to see more hmm what happened
and last on our list of games not shown
is it surprising we didn't see any final
fantasy no I think a little bit like
this is a such a PlayStation focus show
like even just a little bit more I final
fantasy 7 we're not going to hear more
about final fantasy 7 because they
literally I like I think people were
surprised on the development side when
they said yeah Final Fantasy 7 remake
it's coming oh I guess we should start
on that all right really we're not gonna
see that for a while but the sunjin
department it's only knew about that
nobody else did but unlike a trailer for
Final Fantasy 15 maybe yeah but they've
done so much on that game over the past
six months I feel like they've good
they've gone over so much minutia about
how it works you know apart from
spoiling stuff I don't know what's left
to show show me bikes i want to see all
for those people on motorcycles or
customization options for the growler
driveclub x final fantasy put some like
flames on my car check it out trick it
out i'll be micro riders get like Nixon
GTA dlc got no regular gosh put on some
speakers I like I'm here Justin on the
phone right now or sorry so Sony on the
phone right now act looking for you to
sign up at all you're sick ideas and so
I guess lobby and so some of the stuff
do we think we'll see out the
PlayStation experience is not know
burning oh definitely like final I we're
definitely gonna see some final fantasy
we're definitely gonna get a
confirmation of beyond good and evil
definitely gonna get god I think God of
War more some more final fantasy less
guardian I think there could be less car
I think there could be less I think it
got a little more like that what i meant
for this release date release date for
last guardian well like i said we don't
too much longer to wait december fifth
and six just down the road and moscone
center is at the PlayStation experience
and but for fans of Sony video game
consoles it was plenty to enjoy today
let us know what you missed on today's
stream or what you enjoyed most in a
comment box below